[Music]
so good morning
welcome to our session on what's new and
Android developer tools
my name is Jamal listen I'm here with
Gavin tour and today we're going to give
you an insider's tour of all the new and
upcoming features for Android
development as you know Android studio
is the official IDE for developing apps
for Android provided by Google we work
hand-in-hand with the platform to ensure
that all the latest api's and features
are tightly integrated inside of Android
studio it's our team's mission to ensure
that we provide the latest and greatest
tools to help you be efficient and
productive developers I must say I thank
you for your feedback so far and making
Android studio great so Before we jump
into new features
I just want spend a few moments talking
features that we launched since we last
spoke with you last year in case you
missed them so last year at i/o we gave
you a preview of Android studio 2.2
which included things like a new layout
editor the Express load test recorder
and scenic support which is great for
C++ projects and around November we give
you a preview of Android studio 2.3
which included themes like an update to
insert run the lids baseline support and
the constraint layout reaching stable
status which is tightly correlated with
the layout editor and this is past March
we actually a few releases of Android
studio 2.4 but as you know from
yesterday we're not gonna be releasing
Android 51 for instead we're releasing
Android studio 3.0
[Music]
so we made this shift for two reasons
number one as we're developing features
we realized all the work we're going
inside this release didn't seem sort of
indicative of one incremental change
number two we made the tough and rare
decision to make a breaking Gradle API
change and we'll talk about that but
that change allows us to scale it has
staffs or Gradle build speeds so we have
features across the entire range of
feature sets for your app development
from building testing and optimizing
your application so let's dive in well
instead of me talking about it I'm
actually gonna buy tore up to give us a
dim of all the cool features inside of
Android studio 3.0 and after that how's
that come up and talk about the build
system so that torque let's get started
all right so this is Android studio 3.0
it's based on the latest version of
IntelliJ a latest stable version 20 17.1
so we picked up tons of great features
that I'm not going to have time to show
others highlight a couple there's
parameter hints which you see here where
we show the parameter name at the call
site and there's emojis in comments you
know so sometimes when you're commenting
on some slow code you really want to use
a snail emoticon alright anyway the big
news for us is that we are supporting
Colin so in the new part yeah so in the
new project wizard there's a checkbox
now you can enable Kotlin right from the
get-go or in an existing project you can
start creating colin files directly and
the ID will walk you through upgrading
your project dependencies or you can
just take an existing class and run it
through a converter so the way you do
that is to go to code convert java file
to Cottman file it runs it through this
converter and sometimes it does a
fantastic job like here it's realized I
want string interpolation and it's used
destructuring declarations here but you
know you can see also sometimes gets
warnings it's not always perfect I want
to lower expectations a little bit
here's another example here we have a
data class in Java there's a one-line
version of this you could write in Colin
but if you run into the convertor
you end up with code that is completely
accurate but not the most optimal so
this does the same as before in :
so it's really a great starting point
and then typically you massage it a bit
more so here's a Kotlin file showing
several language features you have you
know the four for loop with ranges you
have a left statement with the lambda
and you have a when statement we don't
have time to cover the language today
there's going to be talks about that
tomorrow that you don't want to miss but
when you're starting out you might have
some concerns about performance here you
know like is this going to be expensive
what about this left statement is this
making a new inner class and an object
there's a really great way to find out
so you can invoke the show byte code
window this is going to show the byte
code for the current statement if you
read by code that's great but if you
don't there's this really great
decompile button in the top right window
here when I click on this I get the
equivalent Java code so now I can look
at this and go okay that range loop
turns into a really pure while loop with
index check and similarly the less
statement is just you know a if chuck
so don't prematurely optimize in your
head based on what you are afraid colin
is going to do right you know the most
beautiful calling code you can and when
you're in doubt you can check what it's
doing last thing I'm going to say about
Kotlin is that all the Android lint
Tech's that ran on Java files there's
about 80 of those they're all running on
Kotlin as well there's no gap it's the
same codebase now
alright let's talk about the layout
editor so we launched the new layout
editor last year at i/o and we continued
working on it obviously so one of the
things we have in the new version is
better handling of error since you can
see here and constraint layout we've
enhanced that a lot so first of all we
recently added chains so a chain is a
way to distribute widgets along an axis
so you can select these three widgets
say that I want to create for example a
horizontal chain I don't know if you can
see but there's kind of a beautiful
chain graphic here and I can align this
horizontally and now there's this chain
cycle button so I can basically click on
this to explore how the chains are
behaving another another feature we're
about the launch is constraint layout
1.1 and in 1.1 we have barriers and the
easiest way to explain this is just to
show it I think and so if I were to move
this widget you can see that this line
next to it basically we make sure that
we don't ever overlap with it so this is
a pretty good way to make layouts that
respond correctly and that's actually
all I'm going to say about constraint
layout because there's a whole talk
about it in a couple of a couple of
hours that you don't want to miss
another feature was added in the layout
editor is support for sample data so in
your apps you might have a ListView
recycler view it's pretty common and it
looks nothing like the layout editor
when you run because you're putting data
into it images and of course
applications mystic data so a couple of
years ago we added some support to deal
with this with design-time attributes
the tools attributes right so you could
put some string in and you can start
approximating what your apps going to do
but that's terrible and it lists you so
we've continued enhancing this so now we
have this new sample resource type so
for example I can pull it I can pull in
some lorem ipsum text or I can pull in
let's say a date of the week but the
real power of this is when you actually
define your own data so here is this new
JSON file that I've created in my
project this is for a fitness app so
there's various activities that you know
this app is modeling biking
walking and so forth and there's some
other data associated like distances and
we even have some icons what I can do
now is go into my item layout that I'm
using in the list and I can start
binding these things so code completion
works here for the app sample tag it's
picking out all the attributes from the
JSON file and I can for example hook up
the you know the icon property to this I
can hook up the description property to
this next textview and so when I come
back to this you can see I get a layout
that looks much more like the rail out
alright the last layout and repeats are
going to show is support for a
downloadable fonts so in oh you can
declare downloadable fonts there's lots
of advantages we'll talk about that as
well of course but the way this works is
that I select a text view and in the
layout editor in the font family chooser
there's some more fonts item on the
bottom when I invoke that I can browse
the available online fonts or search I'm
going to pick my favorite finger paint
and you can see I now get this new font
resource in my project and you know it
actually works the way you'd expect
alright another feature we've added is
support for adaptive icons so in the
image asset wizard we now help you
create these so we help you with the
foreground layer you can modify the
background layer I don't if you can tell
from the screen but there's also options
to show safe zones grid and so forth so
this hopefully helps you put all the
right bits in the right places another
small feature that's easy to miss is the
bottom right corner here there's the
device Explorer now finally so here you
can go in and actually explore files on
your filesystem you know you can click
on files to see them locally and you can
right click on folders to upload and
download files and that kind of thing
alright let's talk about thank you
let's talk about instant apps so we have
a lot of support for Internet's we have
a bunch of new literals we have support
in the Gradle build system which I think
is I will talk about we have new Wizards
for creating feature modules but the
hardest part of creating a instant app
is probably going to be to break up your
monolithic app so we're working on some
refactoring tools to help with that so
I'm going to take this simple example
first so here I have a class I'm going
to extract it
so I invoke the marginalize your
factoring and you can see that it offers
to pull four classes out into this new
module and that's because this class
depends on three other classes
recursively and it'll also pull along
with it resources and manifest entries
this is the ideal case that I bet you
will not actually encounter with your
own app here's the more realistic
example so I'm going to try to pull this
activity into its own module and here
you can see it's pulling a lot and we
have some spaghetti because my class
depends on this class which then you
know utils class which is then pointing
it to some other stuff this is real
spaghetti and so what you have to do now
is start deciding where to cut the
spaghetti right and so you invoke this
it creates in your code and then you
would have to actually fix the code
afterwards so this we have an initial
version of this in Canary one but this
is a feature we're very much still
working on we've also improved the apk
analyzer so what I can do here is load
in a apk that is a release binary right
so last year we launched this and we had
a lot of support for resources this year
we've added a bunch of support for for
code and Dex so first of all I can drill
into the deck system here let's see so I
can right-click on a class and we
disassemble the byte code for you you
can also notice that the package name
here is a EI and I promise we didn't
write the code that way that's because
this is a pro guarded APK right so pro
guard has gone and shrunk all the
symbols down to something very short but
now we have this button for loading the
ProGuard mapping file so when i do that
I'm going to find my program mapping
file when I do that you can see that we
now show the original symbol names
instead as you're drilling around on the
text file which is pretty handy there
are some more features here I can right
click and for example generate the key
parole which is handy when I'm comparing
debug and release binary by the way we
have this compare button up here on the
right and I noticed that hey I need to
actually keep this class for the release
or conversely I might be surprised that
this class is in the release binary and
so I can right click and say show me the
usages in the ProGuard code to help me
identify what it is I need to get rid of
we have another feature for apks and
that is apk debugging so the way this
works is that either from the welcome
screen or from the file menu here you
can point to a random apk let's see I
don't know why it's not showing my home
folder
think I'm having Network issues well
that's very sad all right
I'm just going to talk through it so
basically if you're not using studio if
you're a game developer we give you a
way to just point to an apk and we make
a shell project for you based on the apk
analyzer where we show you the sources
inside the apk on the left and then we
let you map sources the Java source code
as well as the shared libraries we we
let you drop in a Esso with debuggable
symbols to stand in place for the
optimized one so I'm really sad that
didn't work all right
next I should talk about the profiler
this is a really really big feature for
us with lots of people working on it and
here's how it works so I've already
started running my app it's an image app
in fact you probably saw this in the
keynote I started running it and so the
way the profiler works is I can now open
up the profiler tab and it will attach
to the process all right no connected
devices
I'm going to run it again
it's very unhappy I'm going to kill the
emulator and start over
this is really exciting television isn't
it all right should work on making that
system image boot faster all right so
here we have it
and no connected devices Wow
you know what I say we there we go
here we go whoo all right okay so the
aliens works is that it's attached to
this process and it's join will show me
what's happening with the CPU memory and
network and so let's go and make some
stuff happen in the app right so I'll
click on an image and Wow
network is very unhappy okay all right
super slow okay anyway it works because
we look in the background here and I
accidentally clicked on the memory
profiler here we have the CPU memory and
network you see these little purple dots
up here those are my touch events you
can also see the activities happening
activity things like stops and destroyed
it's very small but it's basically list
and activity names up here so let's
start with the network this is the time
line I can scroll in so I'm going to
click down in the network area and here
I can see the network traffic and radio
traffic that happened in this time
interval I can zoom in on something like
this and it'll show me the network calls
that happen during that time and I can
click on a particular network request
and sort of see it and the call stack
and the way this works is that we
instrument your app at Build time and
you have to opt in to this so you go to
your run config and there's a profiling
tab where you enable advanced profiling
so basically we look for uses usages of
HTTP URL connection and so if your app
is using that or anything based on it
like volley and we also support ok HTTP
now as of 3.0 canary 1
we've also added support in Android Oh
for for basically doing this intimate
ation on the fly so you don't need to do
any kind of bill time instrumentation so
that will be enabled in an upcoming
build of Android studio all right so
that's the network profiler let's look
at the CPU profiler all right so I'm
going to again click in here and here I
can see the thread activity so I'm going
to jump to be live again and then I'm
going to do some stuff in the app so
I'll click on this image actually I
forgot that what I want to do is start
collecting samples so I'm clicking on
the recording and now it's gathering
more information and then I'll do some
stuff in the app like that and now I'll
stop recording okay so now the timeline
is showing me here that during this
interval we had we have more information
and I can stop I can click on a
particular thread I'm interested in so
the thread displays in the middle here
and we can see that async task 3 looks
pretty interesting so I'll click on that
you can see a flame chart on the bottom
here and this is actually based on rain
dish that I select right so I can I can
narrow my focus on what I'm particularly
interested in and we also have you know
a actually that with the culture this is
the flame chart and we also have top
down and bottom up this place of the
frames so here I can sort in descending
order of method calls for example so
that's the CPU profiler and last but not
least we have the network profiler so
again I'm going to go live so I just
want to iterate it at this point about
this timeline keeping all data I think I
was told about 5 megabytes per hour it's
what this cost so now I'm going to go
live and we're going to start looking to
memory so the first thing I'll do is I'm
going to go inside the app and I'm going
to ask it to clear all of its caches and
then I'm going to go into network
profiler and I'm going to click on the
garbage collection so now we have sort
of a good baseline all right so this is
showing you the memory of the app right
now and let's start collecting
allocation stack traces this means that
any kind
a location that happens in the apps
we're going to record where was done and
the reason for that will be obvious in a
second and now I'm going to do some more
memory intensive activities in the app
you can see in the background the
metrics are scrolling us it's realizing
the heat this larger and now let's go in
and grab a heap dump with this down area
here so now it's fetching a heap dump
and that should be fast yeah so here we
can see basically a summary of the
objects in the heap if I click on for
example the bitmap class there's 70 6/5
I can see those objects here I can click
on a bitmap class and just like in the
old heat viewer I can now start chasing
down the references if I want to look
for a leak but I can also see which
bitmap this is or if this was allocated
during my allocation tracking run I can
see the allocation stack trace where
this object came from and for other
classes for example string yes we show
the actual string so that's the new
profiler we hope it makes your apps
better
and now I'm going to turn it over to the
abbe just going to show you how we're
working to make your builds perform
faster Thank You toe alright let's start
with a new maven repository finally I
know a lot of people asteroid so the
Ural is maven google.com and studying
with Gradle
sort of JIRA milestone - that was
released yesterday you can just use the
Google shortcut so it's much easier and
you don't have to remember the URL we
are publishing all those super libraries
and the Gradle plugin now exclusively to
the repository and we've uploaded all
the previous version of the soup on
every node of the quadrille pudding yet
that will come soon so you can just
start using the web store even if you're
not using the new artifact that we
release yesterday then let's talk about
build performance we know it's a it's a
big problem for lot of developers and we
spent the last few quarters really
focusing on that a lot so the first
thing that I want to talk about is
making a lot of tasks more incremental
so we took at we looked at the biggest
starts at the longest to run and we
looked at what we could do to make them
incremental so the Java compilation is
actually part of Gradle itself
and as of rather than 3.5 it's enabled
by default and it's you know stable
incremental compilation it doesn't yet
support a magician processor but it's
something that we're working with the
greater team to fix dexing in the plugin
3.0 is incremental on a per class basis
and works with biggest multidex as well
so that should make a big difference and
then finally a ticket packaging in 2.2
we increase we release at and the
incremental packages so that we don't
have to recompress entries that you know
different challenge from the previous
build and then we have a couple of tasks
like resource processing we are working
on it using ATT - we've made a lot of
progress for planning to release that
for $3 for the final 300 and then
shrinking if you're using shrinking in
your debug will in order to get 0 the
multidex limits we have an incremental
shrink error that the low predicting and
is faster than just running program so
you can use that just for debug and do
application whisp regarding really so
the second thing i want to talk about is
the bill cache
so greater in 3.5 release a bill cash
that works at the test level so greater
already looks at the hash of all your
inputs and to see if the test is a plate
or not and now you can use that hash as
a key in the cache and if the tasks need
to run but there's an answer in the
cache you just going to get the output
directly from the cache rather than
rerun the task so it will be faster it
should be stable in Gradle father - and
enabled by default at that point there's
different version of the task the first
money of the cash story the first one is
local so it's good when you're switching
between branches and you can able it
today with a greater photo using - -
will cache of the property and then the
other one is the distributed one you
know sharing green cash with your
teammates and your build server for that
you need a storage back-end so they have
a reference implementation on top of his
Urquell that you can use greater than
for price of course epoxy and it's very
simple API if you want to generate your
own back-end so the greater plug-in
freedo alpha one does not have a lot of
cash that are right now matt has
cacheable only a couple of them but we
are planning to roll out more of those
and most of them by the time $3 I know
so that should make a big improvement
now a lot of developers are asking us
okay how should I organize my project
you know how many components how many
modules and how does that affect
performance
so generally more modules mean you can
go around you know lack of increment
skin so in some of the tasks but it's
also useful for other things like you
know code reuse for example you know the
tuner share code across different
application if you want to have better
control over API and dependencies like
your business logic should probably not
have access to some random UI framework
that you're using right but in terms of
performance with caching in particular
then having more modules mean more
chance to have a cache hit and that's
better
and also there's something called
competition avoidance that could
introduce in Grutter 3.4 that we're now
using I'm not going to talk about it
James and Jerome have a talk today at
5:30
talking about building up speed build
speed and they'll talk about it at that
point now we know that a lot of
developers have told us well I'm adding
more modules and now my build is a lot
slower you know
what is so this is really what we
focused on the lot in three Dodos I want
to talk about that now the first thing
that we looked at was just out of course
BB right that configuration time that
happens every time you want to do build
or every time you want to sink so we got
a project from a developer it's about a
hundred and thirty five modules two
hundred and twenty dependencies and into
that so it took almost three minutes to
configure and up pretty terrible so we
finally fix that down to ten seconds in
2.3 but even then we are still doing
things that we shouldn't be doing like
resolving dependencies all the I am even
though you may only be one of them and
we couldn't really fix it properly
without a lot of new API so in
trudeau with bread or photo we finally
think that and it's down to two seconds
we still have some room for improvement
there's some things are not quite
paralyzed but we will do that later so
the other thing that we looked at was
you know bottleneck when you have a lot
of modules and you want to tile it I
used to build and again it's something
we work very closely with the greater
team they did a lot of new API saws and
finally we can fix that so let's look at
an example here here on the Left we have
some tasks that belong to an app that
consumes the library and the tasks down
the right so let's go through what
happened in the build and you know we're
going to basically build all the
elements of the app of the library and
then package them in a big zip file they
are and then we're going to leave that a
are and we are going to consume it you
know on the app so you can see zero
parallelism
that's pretty terrible so again with
those new aps that we have now we can
publish all those elements of the and
there's about like 14 of them separately
instead of just having to publish the
foyer and the bill instead can look
something like that
as soon as the manifest of the library
is used it is available we can keep
building the library but we can start
building the app too and then you have
better parallelism I notice also that we
don't build the AR doll anymore we don't
unzip it so the buildings are so more
efficient that way and then finally
Gradle follower some additional API to
do parallelism inside a single module we
are not quite using them yet but we are
going to start using them soon all right
let's talk about some new build features
oh and I want to mention that you know
it's just a first step writer we're not
saying we're going to three doors gonna
fix everything rightly something we'll
keep investing a lot in and it's just
like a first step
okay so some new good features first I
want to talk about is job eight language
features so it used to require Jack we
announced a few weeks ago that Jack is
deprecated in fact in 300 Jack is
completely removed if you try to enable
it it will tell you don't anybody the
DSL is still there so that we have a
proper message all you have to setup is
the source compatibility on the target
compatibility so the will look something
like this right we go from Java C which
generate Java is classified code to a
converter that convert that to jela 7
class bytecode transform and indexing
the transform is things like program in
some trend but also your own transforms
potentially if you use the transform API
so just as a heads-up later probably in
302 one we're going to reverse this
two-step and do the conversion after so
if you have custom transform you need to
update them to Java 8 classified code as
soon as possible
the second feature I want to talk about
is dependency management so there's a
lot of changes here on trade although
you're probably aware that if you have
an app and a library right now the
library the app only consumed the
release version of the library always so
on the right here you have the
configuration of the library debug and
release and then you have the
configuration of the app he began
release and then compiled and packaging
and you could kind of like go around
that by manually setting up you know
debug compile and then targeting debug
and that would work but excuse flavor it
doesn't quite work very well
ix read other things are more
complicated because for composition
vidal avoidance what we have on the
library side is we publish to
configuration tour volumes so now we
have debug api elements and debug
current time that i meant to be used on
the other side by compile and run time
which were renamed to much the greater
ones so the good news is that we finally
took that in three doto
thanks to new api in Gradle and now the
step do automatically we don't have to
manually try to make that work so let's
see how that works are the high level
basically we have the ability to set of
attributes on this configuration object
and Gradle will automatically merge them
so we created an attribute on build type
for you automatically and then debug
matches debug and then release matters
release if you have flavor of something
right we create a new attribute for the
flavor and then you know blue debug
matches with blue deep
magically you know you don't have
anything to do it's done automatically
now of course if you don't have the same
number of label everywhere it's going to
work too like if you don't them in the
library blue debug is going to match
with debug automatically the attributes
are actually optional however it's if
that's the other way around if you have
a library with flavors but you don't
have flavor in an application then it's
just not going to work and you're going
to get a billy roll and you have to fix
it so we have a new DSL it's called
flavor selection it's not balanced where
we are yet but we're going to do that
where you basically tell the build I
want to pick blue instead of you know
orange and then it just works now if you
switch to 3.0 and you have levels you're
very likely to run into that you're
saying you know hey flavor I mentioned
name is now required which you may
already be doing with two different ones
but not if you have a single dimension
so fixing it is very easy right you know
you have that your code roughly and then
you fix it with that and that's done you
don't actually need to put it in like
level one of the autoblog because
there's only one dimension we can just
fix that for you so the big question is
why do we force you to do that why can't
we just pick up a random default value
so let's look for an example here we
have an app and the app requires debug
orange and then we have two library one
of them with two flavors blue and orange
and the one with strawberry and orange
now you can already see that's not quite
the same orange right and we just not
know so when the app says orange it's
like I don't know which orange eaat so
that's why we asked you to name those
flavor dimension because we're going to
use that as the name of the attribute
and then the name of the attribute is
actually you know color blue color
orange and then fruit strawberry and
then we can make the right selection and
it's the same thing right here to make
it work you have to set up level
selection and in order to do that and it
should not just give us blue but you
need to give us color blue so that we
can properly set that you attribute on
the configuration and then it just works
out of the box okay let's talk about
instant up a little bit so let's say you
have an app you know it has a few module
and AB module with that the application
module some library module and then you
want to make some of those libraries as
feature for your in Santa so the first
thing you're going to do is change some
of those plugin
to beam up library but be feature it's a
new plugin that we released it's part of
$3 all right and what's nice about that
feature plug-in is that it uses the
attribute mechanism I just talked about
so that it publishes both a or at least
the content of the air phone app and a
feature lpk so when an app says hey you
know I depend on you give me your app if
AK it adds to the attribute saying I'm
an app and then it's going to link it to
the right configuration and it's going
to consume the picture plug-in oh you
know as an air and when you have another
module that is an instant up and the
goal of that in some type module is not
to build anything just to package to
grab all of the feature apk and make it
into a bundle that can be referred to a
phone or to the Play Store then the
feature plug-in will actually build a
feature itk something that I can freely
distribute to your phone as a you know
it's not a picture and and that's way
you can really share code without having
to do some web services the regular
module that you have before just change
the plug-in and that's it if you want
more information about building Android
apps there's a talk at 3:30 today that I
encourage you to watch and with that
back to jamming
[Music]
all right so test so now you've
developed and built your application now
it's time to test so we offer inside of
Android studio is a new performant
Android emulator which next released
about a year and a half ago so you
haven't tried it since then I highly
encourage it it's fast and exciting but
after launching the Android emulator we
found about two pain points from
developers one developers want to try
out their into in flow what's the
experience look like for instance my
after that my mind my user actually
download my app or perhaps what's the
experience of an in-app purchase there
is no way to test this the second time
point was around Google Play services
it seemed ever release there was some
lag between the Google Play services and
the Android emulator so to that we added
the Google Play Store to the emulator
now the seemingly small step was
actually a lot of work what we did is
actually I add a lot of quality and
performance enhancements to ensure we
had a great experience when using the
Play Store with the emulator along with
that we also added support for OpenGL ES
300 which hopefully will help you
accelerate your testing as well and
lastly we edit proxy support I know some
of you have enterprise networks are
unique HTT support now we have any UI
that manages that so where to talk about
the impact implications are adding the
Play Store so he's always shipped the
AOSP versions are the Android Open
Source Project versions of the system
images what this allowed to do is have
unfettered access to both the operating
system and your apps by having elevated
privileges in root access but adding the
Google Play Store we actually have a new
variation of it's called the Google Play
edition what this means is now we
actually digitally sign the system
images but that prevents you for having
your root access so if you want Google
Play and Google API s just use the
Google Play edition if you want the deep
analysis and root access ability you
still have the AOSP version that's also
available one additional thing I want to
talk about for the emulator is actually
this new app bug reporting system so we
heard from some of you like hey I'm
going to have a quick way to take a
bucket for it
so perhaps I can share with my colleague
in my QA team so now with one two clicks
you create a bug report for your
emulator take a screenshot has
to do a repo step and put that to your
QA team so as to make it quicker for
user development on the emulator lastly
for those of you who do Android wear
development as you heard with Android
wear 2.0 we now support devices with
rotary support so we added a teacher
inside the emulator for you now the test
at all inside the Android emulator and
lastly about debugging surround layout
inspector so as you saw from Torsten we
have a rich new layout editor which
allows you to add you can straighten a
outs and new themes and styles for your
application but many times you might
have a problem with your layout
something's wrong color or something
that visible are gone so we actually
launched to layout inspector last year
but what this release we added new
capability for better search another
organization of properties to help debug
your layouts for an android ad so lastly
optimize so as you heard during the
keynote we talked about android vitals
and what this really is about is about
the system health about your phone and
the apps on it and when we think about
this is actually sort of a continuum of
information that's available so as you
get system health information now
available through the Google Play
console or firebase now you have a list
of sort of symptoms of what might be
going out your application and now you
can pop into Android studio to have a
deeper understanding what's going on and
have it root case analysis and as tour
showed you at the core this is the
Android profiler so I hope you take
advantage of all these various tools to
understand ranging from again the CPU
profiler understand what's going on to
the CPU the memory usage understand
what's going on through memory profiler
of your application and lastly the
network profiler to get a deeper
understanding what's going on for your
network traffic of your app the last
topic I want to talk about and optimize
is around apk size so as you heard it on
the keynote yesterday we announced
Android go and this initiative around
making Android optimal and smaller so
many times your apk you might have
legacy code or things going out that you
may not serve remember putting into the
app so with 302 as tor demonstrated
we've at now added additional
capabilities to give you analyzer so
again I invite you to use this in your
typical
optimization flow as demonstrated we
added support for
- naps better bytecode support program
pod mapping and much more and lastly I
want to call out a big feature around
vector assets so I'm a big fan of using
vector eyes with myself and it's a great
way to optimize your application if you
must use a bitmap or raster image we
edit web P support instead of Android
studio
it'll be found is if you convert from
PNG to jpg you can save upwards to 25%
and your file size there should be a
huge saving for apk
so again if you right click on any PNG
acid inside our JPEG instead of Android
studio who auto converted to WebP II and
if you want to edit it you can actually
convert your web P back into PNG and was
that that's Android studio so we talked
about a range of features from developed
for adding column support a better job
eight language support better instant
month support inside the build system
add in the Google Play Store to the
emulator and a whole suite of
optimization tools for you with that
that's our talk thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]